Judge Judith Sheindlin, known to most as Judge
Judy, made a name for herself with her no-nonsense
attitude, tough talk, and long, belittling
lectures she gives to people who appear before
her. But there are some other details about
this legal lady and her show that she doesn't
talk about all that much. Since she's too
modest to reveal them herself, we've compiled
them here for your viewing pleasure.
Ambulance chasers
The defendants and plaintiffs who appear before
Judge Judy are neither assigned to her, nor
do they seek her out. All of that is handled
by the honorable judge's producers. According
to a letter obtained by Radar Online, the
producers headhunt through small claims courts
for cases that'd be fun for the rest of the
country to watch on television. In the letter,
producer Julie Turner entices a defendant
into bringing his or her case to Judge Judy
with the promise of appearing on television,
because let's face it there's no better place
to have a personal matter settled.
Producers pay the fines
Even though the show claims all of the decisions
are legally binding, they really aren't. That's
because the fines Judy doles out aren't paid
by the cases' losers, as would happen in real-life
court cases. They're actually paid by producers.
In the same letter inviting the unknown defendant
to appear on the show, Turner promises that
even if this anonymous person loses the case,
he or she won't be responsible for any fees
or penalties. Any money comes from the producers,
which is a sweet deal for most of the people
who appear on the show, as they tend to have
little money. If only real court cases worked
this way! And that's not the only money to
switch hands on behalf of the good judge...
Everyone gets paid
While it may not be as profitable as hitting
the Powerball, appearing on Judge Judy is
a financial win-win situation for both the
plaintiffs and the defendants. If anything,
it's probably the closest thing to an all-expenses-paid
vacation that some of them will ever see.
Turner's letter goes on to say that in addition
to paying for the case's outcome, the show
also pays appearance fees to all litigants
who appear on the program, along with travel
expenses for them and any witnesses they wish
to bring along. Of course, those witnesses
have to have something to do with the case,
but still, a free trip to Los Angeles will
entice anyone to say anything, which often
leads to Judge Judy's next little known fact.
Fake cases?
Obviously, learning that parts, if not all,
of a reality show are staged isn't much of
a surprise these days. But the makers of Judge
Judy can deny responsibility for some of the
fakery...because some of the people who appear
on the show simply fabricate entire cases
for them. Back in 2010, Vice reported that
Jonathan Coward and his friends Brian and
Kate concocted an insane story involving two
broken televisions and a dead cat in order
to get on the show. Coward got the idea from
another friend who appeared on the show in
the '90s, with an actual case. Producers took
the bait and flew Coward and his three friends
out. After the taping, the trio celebrated
by renting a convertible and drinking champagne
in a hot tub for the rest of the day. How
did it feel to take advantage of Judge Judy?
When asked, Coward said, "It felt awesome!
It felt so good." And no, he shouldn't feel
bad, because...
She's not a judge
Though Judith Sheindlin was appointed a judge
by Mayor Ed Koch in 1982, she does not preside
as a real judge on television. The set has
all the accessories and details of a courtroom,
but what Judge Judy does at most is arbitration.
As reported by Consumerist, Judge Judy, and
other television courts, operate under a contract
of adhesion, meaning they "are not bound by
real rules of procedure, evidence, or even
behavior." So on her show, Judge Judy isn't
a judge making a legal decision. She's more
of a mediator trying to solve other people's
problems. So at most, she's just a glorified
middle school vice principal.
She might've taken down a school
When Tony Robb's mother sent him to Cornerstone
Christian School in Clearlake, CA, she didn't
think her son would get locked in a storage
closet for hours a day, but that's what happened.
They later appeared before Judge Judy, hoping
she could get them their tuition money back.
They never could have predicted what followed.
The defendants' testimony revealed that the
majority of the staff not only lacked the
necessary skills to deal with special-needs
students like Tony, but they even lacked Bachelor's
degrees. The principal only held an Associate's
degree. In case you're not informed about
the requirements of a school administrator,
they go far beyond attending a two-year school.
Even worse: the superintendent only had a
high school diploma. Following a justifiable
tirade, Sheindlin awarded Tony and his mother
the total of the tuition money. Sometime later,
the school was apparently closed down completely.
She's inspired others to do good
Marilyn Mosby, who prosecuted the 2015 case
for the wrongful death of Freddy Gray cut
her teeth on Judge Judy. Back in 2000, the
then-Tuskegee University student appeared
before Judge Judy, suing her neighbor for
throwing a baby shower in her apartment, which
destroyed the residence. That must've been
one wild shower. According to the Daily News,
Mosby handled herself like a pro, bringing
photographic evidence of the destruction with
her. She ultimately won her case, and from
there, went on to study at Boston College
Law School. The rest is history. Talk about
stepping up in life.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to see more videos like the one you
just saw. And leave us a comment to tell us
what surprised you most about Judge Judy...